[Music]
[Laughter]
we're late oka snake way supercar
daytime date super duper say a guru now
but still the show as tekzilla is buffet
pardon Caillou what Fujita thought and
he does piece of what this book yeah man
oh man oh man you guys have been asking
for this one non-stop since I put out my
top 10 Dragon Ball Z abridged episodes
video and I had the side to answer your
helpless call for content for I am a
merciful God I will take pity on your
mortal Souls now in case you've been
living on draw rock and somehow managed
to miss the other videos in this
incredibly original series the concept
of which I mean if all about myself when
they'll help whatsoever here's the game
plan
I'm gonna review all numbered episodes
of Dragon Ball Z abridge so that's
episodes 1 through 60 in 10 words or
less while giving them all a score from
minus 10 all the way up to 10 a negative
score meaning so bad it's good so in a
practical sense the closer it is to 0
the worse it is and it will all be with
whole numbers so I can't weasel my way
out of a tough call with coppa answers
like 9.5 so without further ado I am
totally not Marc and this is every
episode of Dragon Ball Z abridged
reviewed in 10 words or less
oh [ __ ] so turns out the folks over at
team forced I are sort of comedic
geniuses and have never really put out a
bad episode of Dragon Ball Z abridge so
to speak which makes this half of my
graph completely useless looks like I'm
gonna have to amend the formula a little
here okay so I think I figured this out
this time around I'm going to focus on
just the positive numbers with 10 being
excellent and 1 being just good good I
guess so if I say an episode is only 1
on a 10 there's no need to make a
response video debunking me ha ha ha
what a story mark the episode is still
enjoyable I'm just trying to account for
the quality creep of the series if you
get what I mean
right ok take 2 I'm toilet mark and this
is every episode of Dragon Ball Z
abridge reviewed in 10 words or less Hey
look another abridged series just what
we needed
okay this one might actually be good
mahogany huh filler episode an abridged
series good cool cool nothing appears
the crowd goes wild
good god Popo is terrifying
man Napa is just really carrying this
show huh cadaver rific and with Napa
dead so two dies DBZ a good night sweet
pretty
nope never mind we're good we're good
let's go to space filler I mean it's
fine but filler stats off kind of slowed
but gets better towards the end in two
three quack Digory is a woman greatest
plot twist since the sixth sense you
know the fishin in line well turns out
czar bonds the exception I've got a
lovely bunch on track impulse to do God
Vegeta's just killing it this season
goran no suponsaa no teikyou de mas
togusa night and day as God is my
witness he is broken in half I've
grieved for recoup higher than actual
family members Oh
not gee wait am i written for the key
muse no the nail inside Piccolo's head
idea is literally [ __ ] genius you
know the patient in line well turns out
freezes the example oh my god Goku vs.
Frieza it's finally happening the
longest get also greatest five minutes
of my life
mere words cannot express my gratitude
towards mr. Popo pink shirt Vegeta is
best girl please adult eggs has stopped
responding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding and the father of the Year award
goes to man I keep forgetting how funny
dr. Jo was I've watched this more times
than I've had hot dinners jo needs to
work on his stealth tactics boomer wants
to bang trunks Thanksgiving is gonna be
awkward yeah oh oh all these squares
make a circle road trip Jesus Christ
imperfect cell needs to be me too ASAP I
demand TFS stop printing East City
Westman jerseys Goku mispronouncing
hypersonic lion-tamer will never not be
funny amazing dialogue amazing fight
scene amazing episode holy [ __ ] Android
16 kicks ass holy [ __ ] tension on kicks
ass you press the Goku button you
shouldn't did that a bridge Super Saiyan
Vegeta is my gender she is for priceless
the look upon your faces fun fact this
final flash is better than the original
fool man trunks get it raw
a nice breather episode after all that
action god I love Goku and mr. perfect
cells banter Android 16th backstory is
officially canon [ __ ] you fight me did
you do today is fighting Dania oh my god
Goku vs. it's finally happening yes
after all this time Gohan's gotta fight
[Music]
worth the wait
worth every goddamn second now obviously
I wouldn't expect you to go back through
this episode to see which ones are the
best in the world but worst is the wrong
word at least best so here are my
personal best and least best episodes of
Dragon Ball Z abridged top 5 number 5
episode 50 if there was some way to boil
down a bridge Super Saiyan Vegeta into
liquid form and shoot him directly into
my veins God knows I'd be living in a
crack den by now considering how often
we have to watch Vegeta get the crap
kicked out of him only to be saved by
Goku I'll take any opportunity to watch
him dominate for a change and holy [ __ ]
does he dominate this episode number 4
episode 56 I've always felt that the
androids were sort of underdeveloped in
Dragon Ball Z but team 4 stars
originally animated scene x 16 back into
the Dragon Balls story is one of the
most intelligent fighting decisions I've
ever seen for Dragon Ball the episode is
funny sure but such a notable and
objective improvement over the source
material definitely earns it a top spot
number 3 episode 36 if there was some
way to boil down a bridge Super Saiyan
Vegeta into liquid form and shoot it
directly into my veins God knows I'd be
living in a crack den by now considering
how often wait wait is that do I'm
getting his weird sense of deja vu
number 2 episode 30 Frieza is by far and
away my favorite Dragon Ball Z villain
and Martin blade his rendition of the
character is by far and away my favorite
depiction of the tyrant - Japanese
performance his uppity bratty attitude
plays perfectly with Goku's idiotic
demeanor it's just a great way to relive
what may be the most iconic fight in
anime history
and the number one episode obviously
goes to episode 60 okay yeah I know who
they're doing the poo saga but it's
important to view this episode through
the lens it was originally presented we
all thought that this was going to be
the end of DBZ a-and this episode was
written as such from the touching
goodbye between goku and gohan to the
epic father/son Kamehameha the cells
beautifully performed swan song for both
himself and the series episode 60
delivers on all expectations and then
some I was fully prepared to accept this
as the series finale making that season
for ending card all the sweeter but yeah
okay if you've seen my top 10 episodes
of Dragon Ball Z abridged video you
already knew all that and if you haven't
why not you should check it out it's by
far the greatest totally not mark video
ever released this is in no small part
due to the man who helped write it a
handsome charming and exquisite love
mech Jesus Tom it's not reading this
it's like three pages long and jeez it's
so graphic Oh anyways here are my five
least favorite Dragon Ball Z Abreu's
episodes man I need a new writing stuff
and a shower
number 5 episode 13 there's a joke about
our lucky number 13 starting off my top
5 least favorite episodes list somewhere
but I'd like to believe I'm above that I
mean not obviously but I certainly like
to believe so now this is a perfectly
fine episode but that right there is the
issue when the competition is so strong
perfectly fine just doesn't cut it
number 4 episode 2 this is another
episode that exists in sort of the
critical paradox the writing is
unrefined and a lot of jokes feel forced
but it's still funny somehow I mean
almost all the gags here feel contrived
but as it turns out even when team four
star fumbling over themselves they still
managed to get a genuine laugh or two
number three episode 12 I feel like
episode 31 and episode 12 are sort of
the antithesis of one another whereas in
episode 31 TFS felt confident enough to
throw out what needed throwing out here
it seems to me at least they felt some
sort of obligation to cover the filler
as the series goes on it's plain to see
how confident they become in their own
abilities and rightfully so episode 12
however exists almost as a relic of the
past number 2 episode 1
you noticed how all of these entries
from my top 5 least favorite episodes
all take place in the early days of DBZ
a it just tends to show how much better
things get as they go on again it's a
perfectly fine episode but that's about
it I mean objectively you should want
your early episodes to be the worst you
produce that's how you know you're
improving so even though Dragon Ball Z
abridged had a rocky start well you
don't need me to tell you how good
things got and finally number 1 episode
4 so ivory watched Dragon Ball Z
abridged and awful lot lately more times
than I care to admit in fact an episode
4 is the only episode I consistently
find myself texting through the princess
snake bit goes on a little bit too long
and it never really lands for me but you
know what the worst part is it's still
[ __ ] funny I mean this is an episode
with popo's pecking order for Christ's
sake and the German homoerotic demons
this is supposed to be the worst episode
damn it why am I still cracking smiles
so I'm gonna hand this one over to you
guys do you agree with my list I'd like
to send a special thanks to Tom again
for writing this week's episode he's a
terrific comedic talent and one look at
his personal YouTube channel will be
enough to convince you of that I assure
you
be sure to check him out and subscribe
if you guys would like to support the
production of further videos on this
channel check out my patreon in the
description down below if you so choose
in any case I've been totally nut mark
thank you so much for watching
[Music]